foreign
bookmark in your book before going to
sleep do you want to knock the book over
in the middle of the night and have to
try to find your place for memory why
would you do that to yourself put a gun
under the pillow like a normal paranoid
CEO of a spy company the book is on a
[__] pillow already why do you have a
Cleaver asking someone who is
unexpectedly entered your room at night
why they have a Cleaver instead of
throwing everything within your general
area at them and then proceeding to
attack them like a spider monkey and
here we see the same animation for the
external shot of the Isis headquarters I
know I've seen it before but since this
is the final episode of the first season
and they couldn't manage to do something
different even a balloon in the sky or
something I'm going for the last end of
the season one time two actual
princesses two at the same time yeah
they were sisters sploosh anyone
thinking having a threesome with two
sisters is the thing to be proud of what
is this you mean besides incredibly
awkward it's only incredibly awkward
because there are no security protocols
for the screen popping open and starting
a live feed you'd think a breach like
this would be an important thing to
address in a spy organization but then
how would the show make any of its
mediocre sex jokes no I'll take steroids
which happen to be available to be in
this little plastic cup which I keep in
my pocket for maximum shock you know the
whole monster hands thing starting the
border on me yeah it's almost as if Isis
should have written up a regulation
putting the kibosh on verbal abuse in
the office before worrying about the
office fraternization issues episode
doesn't show us what's in the Hope's
dreams container and I do not have much
hope that I will be able to dream about
anything else tonight episode expects us
to believe that Mallory would take the
time to be all motherly and wipe the
blood off Archer's chin and I do not
believe you episode I'm beginning to
become very annoyed at the repetition of
the character pulls exactly what they're
referencing out of thin air cliche
there's no reason Mallory has a random
ass certificate from Archer's fake dad's
ROTC 21 gun salute whatever whatever at
the ready her hands are needed for other
things out alcohol and guns come to mind
the size of this coffee cup compared to
the soul of her shoe is making me
uncomfortable I assume those are my only
choices
oh my who else I understand Archer wants
to know whose real father is but this
still falls under asking your mother for
a list of her sexual partners and there
has to be a sin in there somewhere
thanks to technology I can tell you with
confidence that this chunk of text here
has nothing to do with microchip without
reading the entire thing here are my
favorite excerpts but neither spouse
will lead the basketball gate or I would
like to pay in advance and do not ask
for a reasonable price together with
their companions the mountains will give
birth to feathers and great thrust and a
ridiculous Mouse will be born also this
is Latin not Russian and if I am
Archer's father I'm trying to focus on
this ridiculous plan he's going on about
but I can't get over how much unused
[__] space is in this office Reading
also kids oh you're lucky his father's
not here threatening the guy with a gun
pointed at you while you have your baby
you are just so determined not to be
cool about this expecting your
ex-girlfriend to be cool with the fact
that you cheated on her multiple times
while dating her naming your Tavern
Tavern yes please this is the third
sploosh in this short episode and we're
not even to the climax yet what part of
you pay me six hundred dollars do you
not get the part where we don't have sex
you get to say we did he gets to say he
had sex with you even if it didn't
happen anytime he wants this guy would
be paying for her corroboration with his
wild sex story and that specific detail
is entirely skipped in the negotiations
five percent discount for cash I thought
it was 10. oh whoa I can't wet my beak I
mean I think you can until Friday
calling your meat packing company meat
packing these ratchet straps
specifically I will let him or her give
me a handy come on let's share the milk
of human kindness Archer thinking milk
will come out of his dick after getting
a handy dude swear to God she gave me a
Jane Hathaway right on my chest don't
Google Jane Hathaway don't Google Jane
Hathaway
well that wasn't about as I thought it
would be I've always been scared Google
things like that like Cleveland steamer
well maybe that won't be so bad either
oh my eyes my eyes this kitten still
hasn't been adopted in the entirety of
this organization is compromised of
horrible people how can you not take
waffles home how being the kind of
person that pushes the elevator button
for the floor they want to go to more
than once look Lana sincere cheated on
you I can forgive this extra fuge you're
trying to pull off today in his office
but I can't get on board with you
putting your boots on his desk without
his explicit consent Cyril snap snap
girl please making light of someone's
potential mental breakdown and the
probability that they will try to do
harm to themselves or others someone's
in here announcing someone's in here
when there are three other stalls
unoccupied not to mention however many
urinals this bathroom has I'm gonna
pretend you're Alex Karis that's George
Papadopoulos to you Lana we will also
accept [__] show fails to explain how
Sterling made his way back to Mallory's
house wearing nothing but a bloody lab
coat and carrying meat cleaver no one
stopped him or called the police and no
simply saying well it's New York City
does not make it sin proof just like
some sort of cattle rapist knowing what
a cattle this dress is like also leaving
the loaf of bread on the counter
unbagged do you want stale bread because
this is how you get stale bread
and ants just gonna go ahead and sit
myself for not being able to resist the
obvious here's Johnny reference in the
outtakes later all six right in the ten
ring Archer survived all six in the ten
ring
thank you
you can help these children Derek by
killing the prime minister of Malaysia
Sterling hello Mother runtime two actual
princesses do at the same time two days
same time same station
37. get on the desk really
you can put my head in the freezer
I'm not grilling you a cheese I want my
grilled cheese Pronto here's Johnny